Deb comes to us all when we game
presenting us with anger inducing game
over screens and the feeling of defeat
sometimes those deaths are well deserved
but others are just plain dumb the
result of stupidity or simply bad luck
oh and just make note that some of these
deaths can be pretty gruesome and are
not exactly safe for work unless you
work as a butcher or something
death by cuccos we'll start off with a
classic if you've been gaming for a
while then you've probably played the
Legend of Zelda series and if you're
familiar with Link's adventures then
you're probably also familiar with as
many enemies it turns out however that
the humble chicken is a foe that can
give even Ganon a run for his money
antagonizing a cuoco can bring down a
foul doom upon our intrepid hero don't
poke the chickens they will poke back
with a vengeance and across platforms
they do not forgive and they do not
forget until you leave the village at
least hit and run there's a wide arsenal
of available webinar e in Grand Theft
Auto 5 ranging from small firearms to
the death bringing rhino tank and with
so many tools at your disposal you think
that the dumbest way to die in this game
would involve some kind of rocket
launcher mishap or a grenade bouncing
back right nope just like real life it
turns out that all you need to suffer a
meaningless death is to be on the street
at the wrong place and time because non
player characters have no problem
committing a remorseless hit-and-run
this is why we look both ways before
crossing the streets to kill a guy with
an Uzi waterslide of death the 2013
reboot of Tomb Raider introduced us to a
young Lara Croft who was only just
becoming the hardy adventurer we know
today Lara suffers many hardships and
fights against enemies on Yamatai
islands but no amount of shimmying and
shooting could save her from the
treacherous terrain every now and then
there's a section of the game that has
Croft tumbling down a steep hill or
being washed downstream in violet Rapids
if you aren't careful and fail to steer
her towards safety Lara will meet an
extraordinarily grim
and look away now kids maybe just stick
the tombs next time overcooked grenades
anyone who's played a first-person
shooter with in the last few years
should be familiar with the concept of
cooking a grenade this involves holding
an unpin grenade in your hand for a bit
before chucking it at your enemy so that
it explodes on impact instead of
bouncing around on the ground sometimes
though players forget the hole throw it
at the enemy part once you've overcooked
the grenade chances are that you're the
one who's going to be well-done
explosives have a way of doing more
damage to your dignity than your body as
we'll see in our next example rocket
jump fail the rocket jump is a skill
employed by many advanced players in
Team Fortress 2 the soldier as
dim-witted as he is can use his rocket
launcher to propel himself forward by
firing it at his feet and jumping at the
same time it's a technique that many
players master even though it can
actually damage or kill you either from
the blast or jumping so high that your
legs break upon your return to Earth
unfortunate players can also launch
themselves over cliffs which is
humiliating especially when the game
announces that you fall into a clumsy
death careless package getting a small
kill streak and receiving a care package
in the Call of Duty series is a pretty
good feeling this incentive gives
players more of a cause to play smart
and stay alive but sometimes players end
up being killed by their own care
packages which are known to drop out of
the sky hard and fast there are a few
things more embarrassing than being
killed by your own reward except for the
instant replay you're treated to moments
later firewalk this one is a no-brainer
but many players still need to be told
that fire will kill them in World of
Warcraft's dungeons and raids bosses
usually cover the ground with fire acid
or some other kind of goop that reduces
your health a dungeon run could be going
exceptionally well but quickly turned
into a Hugh
masse if someone isn't paying attention
to where they're standing a good rule of
thumb is that if it looks like it could
kill you it probably will so do yourself
a favor and don't stand and fire unless
of course you're going for the suicidal
stood in fire achievement in which case
knock yourself out
literally speaking of playing with fire
romancing morons one small stupid kinda
gross choice in Mass Effect two can end
your adventure immediately as Commander
Shepard you have the option of trying to
seduce any of your crewmates including
the strange and dangerous morons
who's kind of like an alien succubus at
one point she admits to Shepard that she
absorbs the life force from her lover's
and leaves them black widow style empty
and dead Shepard can pay her a visit and
try to engage in a little intergalactic
hanky-panky
but he'll immediately suffer a
soul-sucking death which is probably not
worth it probably so just keep it in
your pants and save the galaxy instead
impatient sonic patience is a virtue
except when you're playing Sonic CD if
you leave your controller alone and let
Sonic stand still for a little under
three minutes he'll get so sick of you
that he'll kill himself by jumping out
of the game followed by some really
creepy funeral music say for yourself
Oh
as far as videogame Depp's go this one
feels like one of the most offbeat and
unnecessary why couldn't he just skip
rope with his own head like earthworm
jim QuickTime events we finally reach
the bane of many a player's existence
and the worst of all video game evils
the QuickTime event in Resident Evil 5 &
6 as well as countless other modern
games you're occasionally presented with
an obstacle that requires you to press
specific buttons at exactly the right
time
failure to do so results in an immediate
death the later Resident Evil games are
so bogged down by these unnecessary
QuickTime events that it's impossible to
avoid at least one or two brutal deaths
starring your favorite zombie Slayers
you'll be caught up in a cutscene and be
totally unprepared for the sudden events
leading to a game over and the annoyance
of having to watch the same scene over
again until you get to the part where
you died why are we pressing a to run
instead of you know actually running
anyhow you'd better train up your
reflexes or you'll end up reliving your
failures over and over again thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know the dumbest ways you've
ever died in a video game